your your bodyguard is so hot oh my God
[Applause]
is he mad
this unexpected moment on Watch What
Happens live I don't give a about
as drama in the Bravo verse dominates
the headlines when she yelled when she
was like I don't give up about workout
like that's how I fight it's quiet quiet
and then explosive I think same this
whole season is insane everyone looks
more beautiful sad on the show first
things first let's address the elephant
in the room we mean The Bodyguard when
Chrissy Teigen dropped by on Thursday
your your bodyguard is so hot oh my God
Stephen yeah we've all been we've all
been he's an ex-marine you guys are all
checking out Stephen and because this is
Bravo a camera was up and rolling on
Steven immediately look he's gonna love
Stephen he's wearing like a jacket today
I know she's gonna be mortified by the
way
[Applause]
is he mad no is that Maddie's got a lot
of kids and a wonderful life and all
right okay he's gonna die
all right well don't worry Stephen the
cameras will stay at Bay because your
boss doesn't see a reality show in her
future and a lot of people think that I
like love conflict or I'd be so good on
like real housewives or something I keep
saying this everybody I get asked all
the time who's your dream celebrity and
I'm like Tegan Beverly Hills I mean I
love everything about it I don't think
fans of the show are necessarily good on
it because we know too much
I watch a ton of Housewives obviously
any one of them would scare the crap
about me because they they can really go
in I don't really think it's a good idea
for me also I'm it doesn't seem like it
but I'm not a I'm not a very I don't I
don't like fighting I'm always like no
no I actually like I enjoy mediation
and speaking of mediation poo poo head
both of you poo poo heads James Andy's
got his work cut out for him in the
three-part reunion for Vanderpump Rules
well it was so emotional as you know
after the season 10 finale aired on
Wednesday Lisa told E.T she's still
reeling from The scandival Saga what's
your takeaway from what we just saw
although as a producer you love all the
ins and outs and the shenanigans when
you're emotionally invested in a group
of people what he did it cannot be you
know condoned in any shape or form but
still to see the answer kind of misery
and the devastation of the Fallout the
relationship it was hard to watch
yeah drama is kind of the bread and
butter of Bravo so Chrissy and her
bodyguard better stick to the clubhouse
[Laughter]
[Applause]
is he mad he's gonna die
[Music]